so today talking about problematic
chromatics or how to make your sites
colorblind friendly
um
we use color as a tool a lot for
visualizations i found this neat little
interactive
about why visualizations are so
important i was floating around on the
internet a little while back
basically we just absorb visual
information a lot faster than we absorb
text information
and a lot of that has to do with
colors
and how we display colors
unfortunately not all colors are created
equal you could probably tell by
the images i'm showing here
which colors i'm focusing on
there are about
eight percent of the population who are
colorblind five percent
are deuteronopia i think i'm pronouncing
that right colorblind which means they
have uh red green color confusion and i
can show you what that looks like
here
so this is what these images look like
to someone who is red green colorblind
so
can't tell the difference between
peppers
the
candlestick chart isn't really useful
there's a completely different number in
that circle and can't really tell what's
going on in the start stock markets
chart
so that's kind of a problem
um
normally when we create websites we can
create colorblind friendly palettes but
this doesn't always fly depending on the
website um if you're dealing with a lot
of market data you can't just make red
and green blue and yellow and
red and green to blue and yellow and
have like 95 percent of the population
understand what that means um
yeah sorry i forgot to
go ahead
um
but yeah so
we can do that
um
but this also doesn't solve even if we
do pick a colorblind friendly palette
that doesn't answer all types of
colorblindness there's like about ten
three of them are fairly common
which i can sort of demo
here
let me go back to the color slide so
it's actually useful
you can sort of see what that looks like
the rest of them aren't but depending on
your user base maybe
it's important so
we're going to
cover a couple different use cases
we basically want to create a colorblind
option for your users
instead of
just creating a site that is accessible
to everyone because we have these other
concerns like red and green
so
the way we want to do that we want to
create a site that
basically
you want it to be colorblind friendly
without impacting development don't
really want to worry about
colorblind stuff in the future as you're
developing
your css or javascript
you need to be able to handle css
javascript and potentially images
and you might want to be have you might
want to support
multiple types of
colorblind users
all right
so let's cover styles first
um
in sas 3.3 you can use default variables
basically this means once if you set a
variable to be default it will only be
set to that value if it hasn't been set
already so if you look in this example i
have i have my application
scss
i set red and green to be default red
and green colors
and then
in my application deuteronopia
i set red and green to be
blue and yellow instead of
actually red and green and then i import
the existing application in there so
basically we can continue doing all of
our um
development and
in the application scss and not really
worry about the colorblind style sheet
because we'll just
it'll just be generated by uh
application due to nokia automatically
so now we have these two style sheets
how do we load this on our site
one way that's pretty common with this
type of configuration is you would name
space your colorblind style sheet
set a cookie
if the user selects that they're color
blind and then toggle the class based on
that
but that's kind of a pain to do
and if you're dealing with multiple
types
kind of gets annoying and we want to
cover javascript later so might get a
little hairy so instead what we're going
to do is get rid of all that other stuff
and just
simply
set the style sheet if the user is
colorblind
and i'll explain what i mean by that
after i talk about basket.js a little
bit
basket.js is a really lightweight
javascript library that allows you
to store your assets in local storage
and it comes with expiry headers and
all that good stuff
a little bit of background on it it was
uh initially created
for
because
storing assets and local storage is
actually significantly faster in mobile
or at least it was
in 2011 when this case study was written
i know i looked at some performance
things
recently and it's still mostly the case
and google and bing are still using
these
still using
local storage asset
still using local storage as their asset
manager
if you look into
uh your brow your browser resources you
can see that which is kind of cool
so
it's kind of a cool article here
i did a little case study uh which i'm
actually going to come back to after
i
show my demos
basically it doesn't hurt
and in some cases it may even
improve in performance
um
so
this is
basically how you would cache a style
sheet in local storage
can everybody see that no that's not
yeah
hold on let me change the resolution
it looks fuzzy on mine now so
i i have all the code samples up too but
basically what's happening is you do a
basket.require pass in the url
for stylesheets you want to set execute
to false and then
here we're setting a key called styles
and then we use this library called
create style sheet to basically append
the styles to the thumb
and it's pretty simple
so once we do that we can toggle
the css that's loaded
by
basically clearing the the key
and then
re-requiring with the correct
css
so that's it's basic it's the same exact
code but instead of requiring
application
uh css i'm requiring application due to
nopia css
so here's a little demo of that
particular thing um
let me just go back to this real quick
because
it's not going to look so great
so here we go here's a little demo site
you can see these are all styled with
css we've got
blues yellows
blue and yellow instead of red and green
here's the toggle
so i click that it's back to red and
green
i click it
it's blue and yellow oh and when i
refresh the page it persists
every time so
yeah
so that's how the css works it's great
so now how do we handle javascript we
basically want to share these colors um
across css and javascript so we're going
to use a
sas plugin called sas json vars
you can find it on github
basically it just allows you to
create some sort of
variable json and import that into sas
and then of course you can use that in
your javascript as well so
that's pretty handy
this is basically how i implemented
the sas here
so instead of having the colors set
uh in application css i import them from
my colors json
and
same thing for deuteronopia i have a
colors due to inopia json and then i
just import them and i'm still using
default variables and still generating
the same style sheets
so
now in our colorblind toggle we simply
override
the colors.json
and
once that's done we re-enit the
javascript
to make to basically just reload it
and
in order to get the colors you can use
the basket api which is down here
i'm just doing
basket.getcolors and then the data
and that'll give you
all the colors
so
let's see what that looks like
over here this is the non-colorblind
version
toggle colorblind mode
works
great
everything's loading correctly
and you can toggle back and forth
all right so we've got javascript
now
images images are a little tricky
because um
you're not always sure what the contrast
will be
if you're changing red and green to blue
and yellow
you've solved the red and green
confusion problem but you're sort of
introducing a red yellow and blue green
color confusion
so
it might be useful for some images but
maybe not all of them but we're going to
cover this issue this
case just
just to say we did it
how we're going to do this is we're
going to use
the image tag in a canvas element
this is a lot of code that's probably
really small
let me see if this makes it any better a
little bit
um so basically what's happening is i'm
getting all of the images on this site
um
and
looping through them
appending a canvas element
and then running it through a filter and
the filters over here
um
basically
if it's mostly red
i'm changing it to yellow by sort of
averaging red and green
and if it's mostly green
i switch green and blue
um
yeah so that's that's where the color
confusion comes in
but
that sort of leaves us
with
this so now
uh you can see the 74.
um the reason it's a little fuzzier
looking to
than than this image is because of the
color of confusion i was talking about
you can see that these points here a
little more yellow
but
this is certainly
a lot better
if i can
this is definitely a lot better than
oh i gotta scroll down sorry
then this where you can't see the
numbers at all so there's definitely a
use case for creating color blind images
maybe you have a picture of a chart
that you want to show
but
it shouldn't be applied universally to
all images
okay
so here's the limitations i was
mentioning
this it is kind of cool though because
you can use the same canvas technique
for
images for video have a little demo hold
on let me
this isn't really gonna mean much
i've got
i've got an image here it's like red and
green peppers and if you look at it here
you can see it's sort of converted to
blue and yellow
is that clear yeah
so that's that's using the exact same
filter that you use for the image and
then just drawing it on the video
so
that's cool
so now we've got video images
um
styles and javascript all handled with
uh
for colorblind accessible
all handle for colorblind accessibility
um
we're loading all these things into
local storage uh obviously there might
be some compatibility issues
there if you're concerned about like ie8
but we're also using canvas elements so
just be out of luck in that case
and we've developed
these tools in a way
that your css javascript
it's all
easily
expandable and you can continue
developing
a couple things i would like to do with
this
i want to auto detect if you need to
filter images basically by
analyzing what
colors are most present i think this is
doable but i haven't actually tried it
and i'd like to use basket with
require.js
there is a
small library that was created by the
same guy who wrote create stylesheet
that allows you to do this but i didn't
get a chance to play around with it so
um
haven't tried that yet
this is the github repo where i've got
all the example code and you can follow
me at tyco's drunk elk
some references if you want it that's
all i got
any questions
yeah you know in regards to integrating
that type of control into the user
interface like
what like uh
like how prominent do you think that
should be like oh hey
yeah
um well
i guess it sort of depends on your site
if you don't have a lot of green red and
green on your site or um
it's not really
a
a huge issue
then i would say it doesn't have to be
very prevalent at all maybe a setting on
like some user page or in the footer
just say if you're color blind please
click here
um
but if you have some sort of like market
data chart
or
a map that has
like red and green colors i think it's
definitely worth
at least putting something right below
that that says
if you're colorblind um please view the
accessible version here
um
it's i think a lot of the times i've
seen it in the past it's in the footer
uh because
again it's it's eight percent of the
population so it's not a huge number
um
but
yeah i guess it depends on the data
you're showing
so there's like a lot of filters
um
kind of
depends i don't really like to
rely on plugins i think that websites
should handle accessibility issues
um
and
color colorblindness is maybe sort of a
smaller one but
um
it's definitely doable and really this
like
once you start doing this type of
development it's not
really difficult and the overhead after
you do it is very small so sort of like
why not and it's kind of a cool thing
so
it seems like sort of real estate is
always becoming more of a concern very
simplistic design so actually having you
know
a link or a text go for
you know adding extra clutter to your
site has there been any sort of movement
towards maybe
an icon or something like that that
could be universally adopted
you mean like uh
so
and i an iconic picture that people
would know to click oh yeah yeah i i
don't know about that that would be cool
though
i'm not sure
in your research so most of this was
focused on
trying to give colorblind people the
same experience with solid colors
um in your research did you ever come
across anything that explored sort of
the alternatives to color like texture
yeah so patterns
patterns is a big thing um
i think
pattern is definitely that better than
what you typically see on websites which
is text
text is not the same experience at all
um i mean if i go back to the example i
had
here oops
um sorry that's work
sorry
no
yes um basically if you look at
this in the colorblind mode you can see
we've got these plus and minuses there
but if you glance at this you're not
gonna know what that means it it takes a
lot more like
brain power to look at that
so
yeah i think texture is good
um i think it's a little more difficult
to apply
with css
and you could potentially
like make it difficult to read text on
top of it but
you know
is there sorry
did you come across any sort of taxonomy
of texture because there's like that
sort of the text on amazon mapping the
color and the reason why we use red and
green for certain things
i found a lot of different opinions
depending on which site you go to
there's actually a couple resources for
colorblind
development
i think i
this this tool i'm using up here is
called color oracle and if you go to
their website they have a lot of similar
tools and recommendations
um
stuff like that is very useful
but
there's there's a lot of different
opinions about what textures are
representative of what
the reason i was focusing on red and
green so much was because those have
very specific meanings
um
textures i don't know of like any
texture that would mean something
specifically
anything
um is there anything to research into
utilizing metadata like i mean we have
alt tags for people who are deaf but
is there any way to or
for the future where maybe a browser
could have a setting where someone could
have a always on flag i think i think
the setting would be great and if you
could read that that would be awesome i
don't know of
any movement towards that
but no i don't know of anything
anything else
do people typically know what kind they
are like if there was a link that said
future
oh
yeah there are tests you can take
basically um you arrange colors into a
palette um and depending on where you
put them uh it'll show you where your
color confusion is so
it's kind of cool
you can
take these tests
one of my friends
took this and he is
multiple types of color blind which i
didn't even know you could be
but
it was pretty interesting
how do they feel about christmas
i'm serious
we're talking about christmas
all right